hello will believe nation welcome to
another edition of the Evan Carmichael
show I believe in entrepreneurs and this
show is all about making you a success
with your company now I'm really excited
about today's show today we're talking
about how to get bigger clients how to
land bigger deals and I know a lot of
you and this is me when I was starting
up to you're frustrated you're not
getting the momentum you want you're not
making the kind of money you want you're
tired of working with customers so we
not respect you or value your time and
now for value what you do enough and
you're not where you want to be yet and
part of getting to that whole part of
reaching your dreams is being able to
work with clients who can afford to
really pay you what your work and help
you build your movement and start to
change the world to the better so if
you're frustrated you're not in that
place yet you're getting your goals
you're not getting big enough clients
yet this show is for you now i'm really
excited here's what i'm going to talk
about i'm going to talk about from my
experience how i got big companies to
fund my product development i'm going to
talk about how i turned a
five-hundred-dollar one-off deal into a
six-figure annually deal and how I got
to work with Donald Trump closing him on
a deal and then sharing my formula for
how to go out and get big clients to
work with you so let's get started okay
you know if you if you didn't 8020
analysis on your customer base if you
look at your customer to look at where
most of your revenue is coming from
you'll probably find that most of the
income comes from a few key clients I
mean a lot of businesses that's not a
t20 that could be 90 10 or 95 5 where
most of your income comes from a few key
clients they're larger they love what
you do they integrated what you have
into their businesses of their personal
lives you are part of their daily
existence now what you want to do is try
to move upstream learn more of those
kinds of clients or even bigger clients
get above them these guys have more
money they have bigger needs and you can
build your business
round them they can lead you to the
promised land now there's nothing wrong
with working with the little guys okay
it can be very rewarding and can be a
lot of fun it's great to see that
personal impact you're having on
somebody's life for business the problem
is that can be really hard and long to
build a significant business off of them
if you're selling I can see more product
and you're going one by one by one by
one it's going to take a long time to
build that up if you're selling to
businesses and you're working with small
businesses and entrepreneurs we don't
have a lot of money typically right
entrepreneurs do not have a lot of money
to spend and so again it can be very
rewarding but it's hard to build a
business around it and a lot of
entrepreneurs they fail they shut down
and you spend a lot of time and effort
and your trainers clients and then
they're no longer in business thanks
what you want to do is identify what
your ideal clients look like and create
a plan to target them now there may be a
few select smaller clients who you can
grow with and they'll spend more with
you as they grow but it's a risky
strategy and I wouldn't bet my business
on it what I want to do is get that plan
target the ideal customers now the
bigger clients can also be your research
and development department they can help
fund your new product and King you to do
it let me give you a quick example in my
old software company we were constantly
asking feedback from customers right not
something you should do you always want
to be talking to customers getting
feedback asking them how things could be
better our smaller kind did you must a
lot of great ideas but most of them
would apply only to that right now I
wish your product could do this I wish
your father could do that but it was
only specific to what they were working
on and we didn't really know how much
other people would really benefit from
having those features in and so it's a
restore us right if we develop it and
only one person wants it that's a lot of
waste of time it's not worth the cost
our bigger clients though they would ask
the features and they pay us to create
it for them arvest was completely
removed and anyone else wanted those
features
would be a bonus for us so let me give
you an example an example within one of
our clients they wanted to have the
software in Spanish get our software
with English only so can you make expand
it without a lot of people you know
spanish working for us who want to be
able to have them use the software and
we weren't sure if we wanted to go to
the spanish market right we didn't have
enough data or feedback from other
people saying hey we really want this in
Spanish that could have been a big risky
move for us to to hire these people to
make it Spanish to have our developers
created for them and in say what we did
is we costed it up we set up day the
higher the translator who understands
kind of scientific language is a
scientific software product it's going
to cost this amount of money and she
then how our programmers go in and
create it it's going to be this number
of nine hours right opportunity costs
are making something else and we put
together a budget so this is what it's
going to cost to do it and they were
willing to pay for that development
costs and we were kind of like mind
blown like they're going to pay us to
make our product better and it's yes
because it's making their lives way
easier way better because we were an
important part of their business so
that's what you want to do right those
smaller guys do they have great ideas
but they don't have the budget to be
able to afford any kind of custom work
or custom development where you can
build your business on the backs of
these bigger customers now as you grow
you'll also find that it takes a lot of
work dealing with any customers but it
takes almost as much work dealing with
the big guys and the small guys until
you're spending all of this time working
on these small bills we need to be
spending the same amount of time working
on bigger deals so I used to be in a
venture capital business the due
diligence process the process you gota
to to fund the deal right you research
in a California you're looking at their
business plans and proposals and they're
coming in and pitching you and then you
got to look into the business more on
check references and call their
customers a lot of work before you put
money into a company
a VC will typically start at around a
half a million dollar range in terms of
investment but it takes as much work to
close half a million dollar deal as it
does a five-million-dollar deal or 15
million dollar deal the returns though
are way smaller on that half a million
dollar deal so the venture capitalists
prefer to go for the bigger deals
because it's the same work but more
money to get the bigger deals you got to
apply this strategy to your business as
well those smaller clients they take up
just as much time as the bigger ones and
this may mean you have to fire some of
your client and I know you know some
people get frustrated and anxious and
you don't want to do it but if there are
small clients that are chewing up your
time and calling in and asking questions
and you know they asking for for new
things that you don't have and it's not
worth of development time it's not worth
going out and doing it for them cuz it's
only 11 customer then you may have to
fire some of those clients and focus on
the bigger ones here's a way to look at
it is this is important discussion you
should have with yourself if you took
yourself out of your business if you
weren't full time in your business
answering customer questions doing
customer support doing fulfillment
shipping product meeting with clients
all the laps up if you weren't in that
part of your business could you afford
to hire someone to come on board and
handle those smaller deals could you
afford the higher so I'm going to come
on board and do that and still be
profitable that's where a lot of
companies is known and that's why you're
making lesson you deserve that's why
some people are working out less
reasonable wage in their own business
because they're working with clients
that are too small if you can't keep
business to the point where you can hire
somebody to come on board and manage
those smaller clients then you focus
should be on going after the bigger
deals and as you grow slowly firing the
smaller ones now there's nothing wrong
with starting some
all you know if you're going to go you
have a goal I want to get I want to get
Donald chump to be a customer right you
got to have something you got to have
some momentum some progress something
the show him nothing wrong with starting
small but you didn't want to stay small
that's the problem that a lot of
entrepreneurs treats they stay small
they've seen the little game and they
get so caught up in running their
businesses the day-to-day grind that
they never remember to get behind to
grow to go up to those bigger deals so
you want to plot that force you want to
figure out who your ideal customers are
and if you can't reach them yet you're
going to aim lower start smaller and
work towards those bigger deals now I
want to share a quick story with you one
of the first big clients I got was a
major telecommunications company and
they hired me and nine other experts to
write for their blog and you said hey we
want you to write 300 to 500 words on
whatever topic you want and we're going
to post on the blog and we're going to
pay you five hundred dollars to do it I
thought hey this is great exposure i was
allowing to done it for free but firing
the box is great I was just getting
started at the time and I didn't just
want to give them what they asked for I
didn't write 300 words for them I don't
know 1500 words and I gave him my video
and I promoted it to my newsletter and I
shared it on my social media I gave them
way more value than what they were
asking for and everybody else just did
the bare minimum right they did what
they were paid to do they weren't
[ __ ] off they just did what they are
paying to do they wrote three to five
hundred words and after everybody
unwritten their post my post got more
views more likes more engaged in more
comments that all of the other posts
combined and so when the company was
looking at seeing as you want to move
forward with I was a natural choice and
I turned that meal into something that
became a six-figure business every year
and that post went from popular dollars
that i charged to 1500 to 2500 I kept
increase in the price because I provided
so much value and this is an important
lesson because if you want to lend a big
customers you don't have to go in and
just go for a huge deal right you don't
go in and after a a million-dollar deal
start with something small so I was
something easy so I was something that
is is so stupid dumb easy for them to
say yes to and then over deliver like
crazy reduce the risks for them by
starting on a small deal and then show
your crazy value don't just given what
they asked for that's that's the entry
price to getting in you got to go way
above and beyond to give that value
that's how you can start working with
big customers oh I get to the call I
have Bernice on the line Bernice where
are you from and how can I help yes a
little Westchester but I only a
barbershop hair salon in the block in
the Bronx alright welcome on board how
can I go after my question is I've had
the business for seven years and we do
our Terran subscribe different ways to
maximize our returns I don't know what
we're doing wrong but you have to be
progress and the hairdresser and the
business was pretty okay it's nice and
smooth but I returns I'm not that good I
mean we're kind of doing different to
receive more because we put out enough
and you know you clean it off including
to your shop and everything you're
getting new people coming in but you're
not getting people coming back no people
coming and it's in a given her my
problem as a business aspect is why is
it that at the end of the year when we
found our returns but we're not get
enough back in return I we do have
someone that does the classic forwards
and stuff is that something that should
be doing different so that I can eat my
returns can be more you want more money
back in the government near the year
what yeah you need a better accounting
for others where I yeah honest is like a
good account and a good lawyer are
really worth their weight in a business
and I know how to start you know when
you first started off we can't really
afford get people to come on board and
you do everything yourself and the
returns are going to be that but you
don't need to hire somebody great
because not getting a lot doc and
returns anyway but using the business or
seven years and you're growing and and
you feel like you should be getting more
money back then you need to work with a
better account
whoo-hoo using right now is it like a
bookkeeper you have a full-on accountant
helping you when on our books our last
five years he said an accountant more so
i guess if he thought he can stay on top
of any changes that we should be at a
benefit on back how could they i would
hope that he ever do that but what
should I look for is if i'm looking
forward to switch them up will be better
where we were kind of no person so
specifically you looking for our tax
account okay somebody who understands
how to maximize the returns for
businesses and what i would do is is
audition them you know you can you can
look up go to google type in bronx tax
accountants or if you have some friends
you can ask them who they are using but
take your books to them and show them
what you're doing and and they'll meet
with you for you know an hour whatever
just as an introduction to talk about it
and see what they come up with see if
they say oh I would have done the exact
same thing or Fiji actually give you
some strategies and ideas to help you
save some money Oh another good try yeah
happens example how much how much you
getting backing and your returns right
now I'm average maybe four thousand
three four thousand a year now and yeah
well we go I catch the year we that's
three four thousand and we spend at
least about 10,000 keep the records of
how much you spend to keep the place
clean and maintain and the tears or
anything like that we keep track of all
those things so it's better than that
and you read like it better with us know
and how much are your accounting fees
how much is your accountant charging you
every year you can charge about 3300 so
yeah okay so I mean you get what you pay
for that's not a lot of money to 5304 to
do the returns he's making just taking
what you're giving them and violent like
there's no [ __ ] that right and I I
mean you don't feel like you can double
your returns right so you can get to so
you can get the ten thousand dollars in
your turns you feel like that's where I
should be then it's worth pain a better
accountant two thousand dollars to help
you figure that out because you know
you're spending more but you're making
even more on the back
I'll go to sonic sense right I don't you
know I mean did you can do you can keep
into I last don't know we do our books
we do our own book even we keep track of
all it necessarily bring everything to
him received and will keep it in
anything like that but if you can kind
of put them together but we keep check
it out ourselves okay and so I mean a
good account will also take it overview
of your bookkeeping nothing you'll have
to deal with themselves but they could
they could give you some strategies for
how to classify everything so that when
it comes to them it saves them time
right so that you're not does you want
to be spending hundreds of dollars every
hour you know when when they could save
you time up front so if you can find
someone who's helping with the strategy
they can also with the bookkeeper in
process and how how you're classifying
everything so that when you're doing
your bookkeeping you can make the
information as easy as possible for them
to be able to continue okay salsa rocks
that is like audition right i mean you
can do it today you go to google type up
rocks tax accountants and and start
making some appointments you use a
lawyer as well you have a tax lawyer
well okay depending on the size your
business it could be something that you
start looking into to how you how you
set up your company structure you know
maybe you need a holding company there's
a lot of tax savings that you can get
what did your business do annually how
much how much you make in right in your
year maybe three four thousand a month
112 so what I got so I'm once you start
getting 100,000 200,000 300,000 once you
start kind of breaking six figures that
may be more the time to hire to
investigate looking at a tax lawyer they
can pay for their weight but right now
you're ready to get a tax accountant and
the money yeah so call me put me where I
need to be up so that can make the
substrate announced I'm not here okay so
if you're pretty instant all right I'll
be calling anyway okay bye-bye welcome
back she doesn't find Michael show I
believe in on
heard and this show is about making your
business it's done today we're talking
about how to land bigger clients and
clothes bigger deal and I want to share
with you the story of how I made a deal
with Donald Trump now when i started my
website at mechanical com one of my
goals was to help a billion people i
want to help a billion entrepreneurship
my website it's a big goal and when i
started it it was just me it was just me
myself and i that was the team i'm sure
a lot of you can relate and i wanted to
start sharing some great content and i
figured you know what who's the biggest
name out there in entrepreneurship who's
the biggest guy who can get on board a
lot of credibility and really explosive
business forward and Donald Trump came
to mind because he was just launching
his apprentice TV show and he was
everywhere and I thought I got to find a
way to get to Donald chump I make this
thing work the challenge is Donald Trump
looked at my website there was nothing
there right there just my picture and a
little bit of information but there's no
momentum and so it doesn't have a reason
to want to work with me I didn't want to
create a negative first impression but I
had my goal and so I started working
towards my goal and here's what i did
and here's how you can model this
success okay i started small i started
small but it didn't stay small and i
started by finding business coaches
marketing consultants sales experts
anybody who had information it would be
of value to entrepreneurs and invited
them to share content on my website so i
did many deals many deals with
low-hanging fruit people who you know
they were just looking for any kind of
exposure and i was giving it to them so
they didn't really care about what i had
built up yet which was nothing and then
we started helping them and i started
with finding the model I misheard you're
making mistakes with them and figuring
out how it could get better and gives
them more value and when I built it up
and I knew I had something that was
working i said okay I'm ready to grow
now I'm ready to grow and I wanted to
move to the next year right along the
along your you're
to your goal did that they dream they're
steps at you have to take so my first
step was the low hanging through dealing
with anybody who had content the next
step was I wanted to reach out to
somebody was a little more well-known
not Donald Trump level yet but a little
bit more well known and so I wanted to
get guileless boxing Seth Godin and at
the time they were big names in bloggers
they have books that are highly
successful you should read them i
recommend them and so I started reaching
out because I didn't know what either
though you know they weren't they
weren't my best friends I didn't know
how to get in touch with them and I said
asking my friends of it networking and
it came across a guy who knew guy and a
guy who knew guy and and he set up that
introduction for me he was willing to
introduce me the guy kawasaki chef
golden I didn't have a contact in to so
I just reached out to him and I
passionately let him know what I was
doing and if there's a way that we could
start to deal together and both of them
said yes so through my networking I got
the guy and just threw a passionate
email that the set both of them said yes
and I started working away on using now
their names to get into the next step
and I knew their names and credibility
to help me get Michael Gerber her of the
email and Zig Ziglar and jack canfield
and all these other bigger names and
then I used their names to go and get
Donald Trump and Trump was watching his
Trump University which is a program to
help entrepreneurs and was looking to
you know have more headway into the
small business space and I connected to
him to chuckle University and they said
yes and so it's starting small but not
staying small and building your step
stop it started with whoever i could
find writes the loaning you to customers
then moving one step up to God Kawasaki
and seth godin then moving one step up
to getting jack canfield and Zig Ziglar
and those guys and then finally going
out there gone up shopping by the time I
got the hand there was so much momentum
so much traction built up and i used the
names of everybody who was with me at
the time that was the easy decision to
say yes to so that's how you start you
start
but you don't stay small continue
building step by step by step so you get
to the big fish I have Antonio on the
line Antonio where are you from and how
can I help hey how are you I'm great man
what's up I'm from lufkin texas i have a
brand that's called just be you I just
started it because I recently decided to
come clean about a lot of things and
just do you started from my childhood
and the things I went through at the age
of 12 and up to now to prison and this
brand I'm trying to get it out I'm
trying to get my story out there i'm
trying to get people to notice me I have
a fan page so far but it just seemed
like it's just the same you know this is
not going as fast as I wanted to
basically I have friends that support me
I have faced a lot of Facebook friends
that shares my story or whatever what
happened and what was going on behind
just be you I have no idea if I want to
start a book or if I want to do clothing
I don't know how I go about it but
that's what I really just need the
advice on how to get it out there how to
get myself horn because it's just seem
like it's in the same spot I love it so
the message is clear easy just for you
something people can relate to how you
want to be able to introduce that next
is by quickly and library on that right
so why is it so important that you have
to just be you because I know it's a lot
of people out there they can relate to
my life story and what I've been through
and to be like it's just okay to be you
it's okay to open up its ok to say I've
been hurt and not in that way about what
anybody else has to say just be you and
this is something that I feel like a lot
of people can relate to you know but I
can't get it to everyone who could
without you know no supporting anything
so I really just stuck in a vine on
where to go with this who is your
audience is that kids is this young
ounces and everybody it's honestly it's
everyone but I'm really more so looking
at the young the
up to the middle age because they can
relate to you know of course with all
the armed police brutality child abuse
central molestation um and also with me
being again male you know in the stuff
that I went through as trying to get
just view up to with that you know
people just tend to be down because of
my sexual orientation you know it's a
lot behind the story behind my story
about what I went through just as far to
just be you but it is I came to get to
the if I can't seem to just get
everybody to share my story I can't you
just get to everybody just notice me but
I need help on who you know what was
best massage social media like I mean
what i would recommend doing it's
starting to leverage other people's
brands here okay so you're trying to
build up your own brains just like i did
when i started associating with Donald
Trump and jack canfield and Ziggler
Ziggler built up my friend and the
people started paying attention so the
same thing can happen with you in the
field of of just being you and what i
would do is pick one medium if it's
whatever whatever you feel more natural
at if you like writing then do a blog if
you like doing the radio if you like
speaking and do a podcast or radio show
if you like doing videos and do a
YouTube channel and I start reaching out
to people who you know have gone through
some of the same stuff that you've done
so so if coming as a cloud and saying
hey I'm gay with a big thing for you
then find other people who are more
established or more well-known and more
recognized and and interview them and
you can share part of your story but
also you're bringing on these people to
come on board and help you so here's an
example on writing the book called one
word and interviewing people like the
town there's an honest which is
Christopher Gavigan and Jessica Alba and
so telling their story helps build up
leverage around the concept of one word
in the book on Monday so who can you
interview who's gone through and there's
so many people right who've gone through
this child abuse and
coming on the closet and being gay and
you know being made fun of and all of
that everybody has a store that they can
share that can relate to it and to
creating an ongoing media channel
whether it's like blog podcast lat radio
show or YouTube video interview channel
that you can leverage their names and
their stories but at the same time build
up your brand in the process okay I
didn't even look at it I finished that
sounds like a plan okay sue somebody
retires come out of the closet who who's
somebody look up to and like he did it
like the Tim Cook from apple just came
out of the closet that he was gay right
the president of that right yeah not to
be a goal of yours to go an interview
Jim cook right I maybe it starts smaller
and you build up your your platform but
if it can cook or if it's you know Magic
Johnson coming out and saying he had
AIDS back in the day or HIV back in the
day I'm using them to help you build up
credibility and then when they when the
interview launches they're probably
going to help spread the message right
if somebody has a following on social
media said hey I was just interviewed by
Antonio go check out this podcast as its
YouTube video so really how the road I
brand okay okay okay okay um about 10
with that do you think that the the fan
base pays I got going on I need to keep
that up also I'm I would focus your
efforts picked it one thing that you
love doing most and pour all your
passion into it and journey we gotta go
thank you so much for calling good luck
to me posted with your program welcome
back to heaven Carmichael show I believe
in entrepreneurs and today we are
talking about how to land bigger clients
so I want to share with you my 4-step
process okay number one you have to know
who you want this is really important
you can't just be any I want to have
bigger clients you gotta have a target
you got to know who you want to go after
for me it was Donald chump right I
wanted Donald Trump to be involved in my
business somehow that was my goal and I
work towards it so you got to know who
you want number two if you can't get
that works right now aim lower it's okay
you got to start smaller build momentum
go step by
by step continue pulling people sweaters
to get higher up the ladder that's how
you do it but just don't stay small so
many people have this big goal and then
they start small I may just keep staying
small and they don't take the next step
up you mean I both can smell the Trump
but you go small to medium to large to
extra-large the trunk right you got to
go through that process number three
when you make that list of people you
want to reach out to start reaching out
right reach out to them connect to them
let them know what you're up to let them
know where you are let them know how you
can help them and number four keep
reaching out and this is a key because
most of the time it doesn't happen on
the first time you got to follow up you
got to stay in touch you got to keep
providing values and it's not just
calling up and saying hey you ready to
buy something yet you ready to do
something together you should be a known
quantity okay you want to be following
them on Twitter and comment on their
stuff you want to be connecting with
them on youtube and google+ and linkedin
wherever they are when they're
commenting and sharing stuff you want to
be there they should know who you are
you see something in the media and the
news an article a story a book that you
think could help them you fire that off
to them we want to try to add value so
that when you are top of mind with them
when they have a need they're going to
go to you first okay that supports that
process use it leverage it start to grow
your business again bigger deal number
one nobody want number to a more if you
have to the retreat reach out number
four keep reaching out I got time for
one last caller we're going to the lines
I've got Joey on the line Joey where are
you from and how can I help from Long
Island New York how you doing well you
just answered a lot of my questions
right there but what a basically I am is
I'm a professional DJ comedian and a
singer so what I was trying to do was
try to be different and I wanted to
package all my talents into a go one man
show type of thing I started a website
about a year ago and I'm getting you
know i'm surprised i'm only getting
maybe three or four gigs in that
direction and in a great party is great
to wear you know everything i'm shooting
for us is working out rates just a
matter of like you said targeting
finding out where i get those type of
clients
facebook in it and twitter in it and all
that type of stuff but I'm even thinking
about me to get a local commercial here
on Long Island to promote myself are you
doing weddings or corporate advisor who
is your audience well no weddings and
stuff like that I keep separate but what
I'm doing corporate events or if I'm
doing up birthday parties stuff like
that more entertainment the better you
know so I'm trying to take all my
talents together and put them into one
party and it's a great idea and it works
great when it happens and I really have
to sell the idea but it's not catching
on you know I've been doing it for about
a year now and like I said I like four
or five parties in the last year I get
regular party so I'll get regular
weddings and sweet 16 and stuff like
that but I'm right a lot of market this
you know I mean it's like people don't
trust it because it's new it's different
so my trust me it's good so yeah I think
if you're looking at social media your
best bet is going to be YouTube like I
want to see this because as you're
grinding it you're saying what a
comedian singer like i wanna i want to
see your show i I have a huge i have a
website and i have videos on the website
but um I can't stay in traffic into the
website I'm you know it you know I have
business cards word of mouth it's just
uh I don't know people are spending
extra money a lot two histories I can't
figure out why something like that one
catch on I know I would want it at my
part yeah so the two things that would
look at is one so it's great to have
video i put a few more videos up there
beyond just one show and see if you can
have somebody I don't help professional
that first video is but it's actually be
doing corporate they want to see
professional so it might be worth having
helped to record one live show that's
done professionally because it's a good
reflection on your brand so i would i
would also see if I can get some
testimonials on video so those four
fires that you did can you go back to
some of the people in the audience and
say then that Joey is crazy you made our
event like the talk of the town was
awesome you got to get him on board just
so that you said like its new people are
scared they are fearful they don't want
to make the company look bad
so having somebody come on and say how
great you were can add a lot of value
and reduce the risk for new people
coming on board right now it's the risk
if the trust factor they'll trust it
it's like I tell about it down the warp
6 great a lot of fun and now we'll just
stick with the music you like I you know
we're going to go I got to force some
somebody to change the other thoughts
but us right and it's great that it's a
medical like you really have a business
and this is an upsell for them but i
would get those two halves of the manual
videos no i don't know i could probably
go back like you said go see the people
that i did the parties for were very
happy it'd be no problem to contact them
some kind of testimonial yeah I mean
that's a huge risk reduction because of
course you're going to see how great
everything is right no no I'm snoring
would say oh this is you know I'm just
I'm just trying to upsell you and take
your money you know but having customers
glow about how great you were as a lot
of value and really reduces my risk if
I'm on the fence and I see a great
customer testimony or a couple of them
from like a company I might recognize
like I want to do it for those guys and
I'm really happy okay let's try it um
the other thought I had was I would
start working with event organizers
event planners instead of trying to go
direct to the corporate because a lot of
the bigger corporate they don't do their
own stuff they hire event planners to
manage it for them and okay and if a
good event planner will have multiple
clients instead of trying to sell one
client at a time if you get an event
planner to love what you're doing he or
she can sell you into tons of dates
dozens of the hundreds of gigs because I
that's their job right so you could say
okay well here's a you know he can join
him give you the music but if you want
something extra special you know here's
the video and use decimals to back it up
maybe you should consider this complete
package right right right yeah that's
what like always like Oh Liz to be
different to do something I try to get
you so I wasn't I'd make a list of all
those people who are event planners in
the area you get way better returns out
of that and taking out a commercial on a
radio station okay and also branded
something like call it something that i
will remember you know right
like I don't know what you're going to
call but something that that's memorable
that that sticks in my head is something
extra special right right Joey good luck
yep ok thank you that thank you awesome
thanks for calling in hey we're at the
end of another hour it's crazy how time
flies I want to thank my producers Josh
and Christy it was Christie's first show
she hit out of the park thank you so
much crispy for the great show when I
come back I'm going to be on in two
weeks again talking more strategies that
help you grow your business until then
keep strong keeps grinding it about keep
hustling and keep believing thanks fans
have a great couple weeks